This was
um when we had to wait for her to wake
up
this is baby Isabella coming round from
a general anesthetic in January but her
operation hadn't gone ahead due to a
shortage of Staff she had to wait
another week for surgery for a rare
condition that affects her colon then
earlier this month she became ill again
so her mother took her to hospital in
Dudley we are going into Annie you are
discussing because what's going wrong
with your daughter who had just
operation
so we went into a e
and it's just a constant waiting
the series of delays have left her
mother concerned about the impact
escalating strike action could have
I don't blame the nurses doctors they
they do their their job and they're
brilliant
but obviously they're also under stress
if more stuff goes on on strike
I don't know how that's gonna work like
honestly waiting for long hours because
there's not enough stuff
somebody really should step in and and
do something because there are people
and children stressing and suffering in
hospitals
the Royal College of Nursing is
preparing to intensify action which
could see staff also walk out of
emergency departments intensive care
units and cancer wards but Roman is a
nurse who works with cancer patients
aren't you concerned with this
escalation that actually patients are
now just going to feel very frightened
about how their care will be affected
I think my patients know that this is
necessary and they're standing in
support behind us
um that's I see patients appear on the
picket line saying keep on going this is
for us we know you do this for us don't
you risk losing that support by
escalating this
I hope not because I hope the public
will understand that this is in the
hands of the government
new strike dates could be announced
within days and take place in the coming
weeks NHS providers which represents
Hospital trusts has said it's alarming
and warned the only way to avoid more
disruption is fresh pay talks a
government spokesperson said the Health
and Social care secretary has been clear
he wants to continue discussing with
unions what is fair and affordable he
continues to urge unions to call off
strikes and engage in a constructive
dialogue about the pay review body
process for the coming year
like many patients Isabella's mother
just wants the row resolved so there's
one less thing to worry about if she
falls ill again Becky Johnson Sky News